hey everyone bandit here do you like
five nights at freddy's fanaf for those
in the know you like the story the lore
theories even if you answered yes to
even one of those questions then you
have no doubt come across at some point
the videos made by the one and only
matpat of game theory i don't know why i
made a fist right there that was a
little weird but matpat of game theory
the prometheus the king of five nights
at freddy's
actually that's markiplier matpat is the
theory king of five nights at freddy's
and both of them sit up there in their
thrones looking down on the rest of us
little peons and they kind of laugh
if you've been following his videos then
you'll know that his recent video was
about a couple of different things it
was about bonnie and explaining what
could have happened there and it was
also about cassidy
you know that should sound familiar for
some of you who have been around here on
my channel it's about cassidy and golden
freddy being within the princess quest
minigames freeing vanny from the
clutches of glitch trap afton
okay but before i personally had even
gotten the chance to watch his video i
had comments pouring in on my previous
fanaf theory video about
bandit did you watch matt pat's recent
theory video banned it i wonder if
matpat watched this theory video i
wonder if matpat knows that this video
is out there and it got me really
curious i was like huh
what uh what's going on here i wonder
what these people are talking about and
then i went and saw the video for myself
and uh
yeah i i get it now i get it now
basically what happened is the first
part of matt pat's theory about bonnie
is completely new i haven't heard it
before it's amazing and beautiful the
second half about cassidy golden freddy
is basically my theory just matpat goes
a lot more in depth in certain cases as
he is known to do like he translated
some of cassidy's glitchy text into it's
me which is mind-blowing i didn't even
know to do that so
that's phenomenal which is why matpat is
the theory king of five nights at
freddy's the reason why i'm bringing it
up though is that my theory video which
came to the exact same conclusion and
pointed to a lot of the same evidences
was made about two weeks before his
yeah i mean look at the thumbnails
here's my original thumbnail
somewhere on the screen and then here's
the thumbnail for his video as you can
see my original thumbnail was extremely
similar to the thumbnail that he made
for his video that is live right now now
the reason why i'm making this response
video if you will is because a lot of
you were asking me what i thought about
this since you know i made an extremely
similar video that was
you know somewhat popular not like super
popular what was somewhat popular as far
as fnaf theories go so let me answer
that question here's how i feel about it
i feel
awesome i feel like i am walking on
cloud nine i'm not upset about this at
all i i let me get this let me get one
thing straight let me let me say it real
clearly so that my voice just resounds
to the back of your room and then
reflects off the back of your room and
smacks you in the back of the head with
a second dose of realization i am not
trying to make any clout here or stir up
any kind of negative feelings i
love matpat he is extremely influential
to people like me and and probably many
many thousands of other creators here on
youtube so please don't take any of this
against matpat or his team they're
beautiful beautiful beings and i love
them all very very very much instead let
me paint it this way for those of you
out there who have ever been involved in
sports or any kind of art
you know drawing
fencing acting whatever if there was
ever a personal hero of yours that you
looked up to which is extremely common
for artists
imagine for a second that that hero that
you had in your mind you figured out one
day that they basically do
something that's key to that art exactly
like you do it
like if you look up to leonardo dicaprio
as an actor and you figured out that he
has the same warm-up routine as you or
something i don't know
you would be ecstatic would you not it
kind of humanizes them but also kind of
connects them to you and makes you feel
a little bit more encouraged about
yourself and that resounds very true for
me right now if you've been a fan of my
channel for a long time then you'll know
that i am extremely new to the five
nights at freddy's franchise in general
and the response has been great which
i've been very very grateful for but
it's still extremely nerve-wracking
those of you out there who might be
creators probably can relate to me on
that but knowing that i
have at least for this theory of mine
thought the same and come to the same
conclusions
as the theory king of five nights at
freddy's
two weeks before him
is the most enlightening thing
ever
and i don't even know how to follow up
on that so basically i just wanted to
make this video and give my statement to
you guys at least the ones of you who
were wondering about what i thought uh
regarding his recent theory video being
kind of similar to mine
i'll be at a lot higher quality on the
other hand because i'm feeling so good
about myself right now and probably
better than i should be given
my overall size and quality of videos i
can't help but wonder since matpat and i
have recently been proven to have the
capacity to logically come to the same
conclusions and even come up to the same
ideas of thumbnails
i can't help but just kind of wonder in
my little boy dreaming heart
what we might be able to do if we worked
on a theory together
about fnaf
now listen that is never ever ever going
to happen i realize that
i don't have 10 of the viewers he has i
don't have 10 of the subscribers he has
i don't have 10 of the editing
quality that he has this is just me
being very human in front of my audience
and sharing with you
a dream that i have so that you can all
just point and laugh at me and my
vulnerability ha ha there i'll laugh
with you and you know what
while you're laughing at me why don't
you point and click on the like button
and also subscribe to stick around
while you're at it that'll make up for
it you know since you're laughing at me
and all point is something like that is
is really not going to happen but i did
want to share it with you guys basically
so that i could get a feeler on if you
guys would be interested in me collabing
with
matpat
in a dream world at some point in
another reality or maybe even other
fanaf youtubers uh that cover the lore
and stuff like that and speaking about
the matpat thing i mean
something like that would never really
happen unless there were
to be some sort of noise about it
happening and it's not the kind of noise
that i would be able to make myself so
again if you guys want to see that
happen then we're going to have to do
things like share this video we're gonna
have to do things like you know hit him
up on reddit tag him on twitter you know
comment on his videos whatever so if you
guys want that to happen let's at least
give it a good old try to try to make it
happen but nobody gets to do a video
with him don't put your expectations up
there let's just take this one step at a
time i wanted to end this by thanking
you guys once again for the great
turnout on the now two final videos up
on my channel
which i'm
extremely excited for that's why i made
this entire video and i would not have
ever done the second one if there was
not a great turnout on the first one so
once again thank you so much for that
i don't really know how to end this
video because i've never really done a
video like this
um so
i'm just gonna
i'm i'm gonna grab my hand sanitizer
and my kirby
and my little action figure of jinx from
arcane
and tell you goodbye i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day
this is masintana bandit looking forward
to seeing you next time peace